Alright Charles you want to help us kind of work through this example?
>> Sure. So ,we multiply x1 times w1 so that gives us a half
>> Um-huh.
>> We multiply zero times three fifth which would get a zero.
>> And we multiply minus one point five times one. Which will
give us minus three halves. And so, the answers negative. Whatever it is.
>> It is right, so it's, this was negative ahead, negative one and
a half plus a half, so it should be negative one.
>> Right.
>> And, but that's not the output that we should actually
produce, right? That's the activation. What do we do with the activation?
>> Well we see if the activation is above our threshold fata, which in
this case is zero, and it is not So the output should be zero.
>> Good.